- [Instructor] Hashem obtained
a random sample of students
and noticed a positive linear relationship
between their ages and
their backpack weights.
A 95% confidence interval for the slope
of the regression line was
0.39 plus or minus 0.23.
Hashem wants to use this interval to test
the null hypothesis that the true slope
of the population regression line,
so this is a population
parameter right here
for the slope of the
population regression line,
is equal to zero versus
the alternative hypothesis
is that the true slope of the
population regression line
is not equal to zero at
the alpha is equal to 0.05
level of significance.
Assume that all conditions
for inference have been met.
So given the information that we just have
about what Hashem is doing,
what would be his conclusion?
Would he reject the null hypothesis,
which would suggest the alternative?
Or would have be unable to
reject the null hypothesis?
Well let's just think
about this a little bit.
We have a 95% confidence interval,
let me write this down,
so our 95% confidence interval,
we could write it like this
or you could say that it
goes from 0.39 minus 0.23,
so that'd be 0.16, it goes from 0.16
until 0.39 plus 0.23
is going to be 0.62.
Now what a 95% confidence
interval tells us
is that 95% of the time
that we take a sample
and we construct a 95% confidence interval
that 95% of the time we do this,
it should overlap with the
true population parameter
that we are trying to estimate.
But in this hypothesis test, remember,
we're assuming that the
true population parameter
is equal to zero and that does not overlap
with this confidence interval.
So assuming, let me write this down,
assuming null hypothesis is true,
we are in the less than or equal
to 5% chance of situations
where beta not overlap
with 95% intervals.
And the whole notion of
hypothesis testing is
you assume the null hypothesis,
you take your sample, and
then if you get statistics,
if the probability of
getting those statistics
for something even more
extreme than those statistics
is less than your significance level,
then you reject the null hypothesis
and that's exactly what's happening here.
This null hypothesis value
is nowhere even close
to overlapping, it's over 0.16ths
below the low end of this bound.
And so because of that, we
would reject the null hypothesis
which suggests the alternative,
which suggests the alternative hypothesis
and one way to interpret
this alternative hypothesis
that beta is not equal to zero
is that there is
a non zero linear relationship
between ages and backpack weights.
And we are done.